MIKE FOX: Hi, everyone.
I'm Mike Fox from the developer
marketing team.
It's my pleasure to introduce
today's speaker.
I met Michael Mace when we both
worked at Apple, and he
was the director of competitive
analysis, and that
was prior to him leading the Mac
platform marketing group.
After he left Apple, he came to
Silicon Graphics, so this
campus is pretty familiar
to him.
Since then, he's worked in a
number of companies, including
at Palm, where he was the vice
president of product planning
and chief competitive officer.
He's consulted for a number of
companies throughout Silicon
Valley and the tech industry,
and he's currently the
co-founder of [INAUDIBLE] and
a mobile strategist at
usertesting.com.
Now, he shared his deep
experience in product and
business strategy in a hands
on business strategy guide
called "Map the Future,"
which he's going to
talk a bit about today.
It's currently available on
Amazon and a number of other
marketplaces, but hopefully, you
guys can help me get him
on Google Play when we're
done, as it is an ebook.
Now, because the book covers a
wide breadth of topics, he
offered to focus on an area
that should be really
interesting to Googlers, which
is how different companies'
attitudes towards the future
impacts the effectiveness of
the strategies they
create and follow.
So please join me in
giving a big Google
welcome to Michael Mace.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL MACE: Well, thank you
very much, and it's very, very
cool to be here.
I'm really excited about it.
So I'm going to try to cover a
lot of ground in a relatively
short period of time.
So let me address how we'll deal
with questions right up
at the start.
So there are two types of
questions-- questions of
clarity, like I don't understand
what you're saying,
or could you give me a little
more detail on that?
Chances are if I've confused
one of you, I've probably
confused many of you
in the room.
So if you have that sort of
question, wave your hand,
throw something, whatever's
necessary to get my attention,
but please ask it right away.
The second type of question is
questions of discussion, like,
oh, I want to add an interesting
anecdote related
to that point, or, I think
you're an idiot, and I'd like
to explain why.
I'm completely up for having
that sort of discussion, but I
want to do those at the end so
that you can see the sum of my
information.
So if you're confused, though,
please ask stuff right away as
we go along.
So before I get into telling
you the content, let me
summarize what I'm going
to talk about today.
So we as an industry and as a
society are usually, in my
opinion, wrong when we try to
think about the future.
And I'll give you some examples
on why I say that.
And the reason is because
we think about it
in the wrong way.
We either try to control the
future, especially in terms of
businesses and doing business
planning-- we either try to
control the future through
incredible vision that we
have, and we're just going to
impose our vision for the
future on customers and on the
marketplace, or we try to
analyze our way through
the future.
It's like, let me see if I can
figure it out in enough detail
that I'll be able to tell
exactly what's going to happen
in the future, and then
we'll just react to
whatever's going to go on.
Both of those perspectives end
up having big vulnerabilities.
To get it right, to do a better
job of looking at the
future, you need to be able to
mix a couple of different
perspectives and different
thinking styles.
So specifically, you've got to
get specialized information on
customers, and competitors,
and advanced technologies.
And second, you've got to
be able to tap into both
intuitive and analytical ways
of looking at information.
And so I'm going to talk today
about the background behind
that, how you get it right, and
kind of give you a general
framework around this.
So you already heard the
background on me.
I've been in the industry for
quite a while, and I've done a
bunch of things.
And once you've been in the
industry, you start picking up
on trends that you see--
repeated things.
And I'm sure some of you guys
have experienced this as well,
where you start thinking,
gee, wasn't that tried
before and it failed?
Why in the world are they
doing that again?
Or, gee, that's not supposed
to work, but it actually
worked this time.
What in the world was
going on with that?
And so I kind of had the
same experience.
And one of the things that I've
seen over and over and
over again is that-- forgive my
language-- but we suck at
predicting the future.
I mean, we just do
a terrible job.
And to give you an example of
that, I'm going to pick on a
book, which is actually
a really good book.
This is one of the bestselling
business books of the 1990s.
It's called "Competing for the
Future." If any of you have
ever done business classes in
college, they force you to
read this one, most likely.
And it's not at all a bad
book, but it's really
emblematic of the problems
we have about
thinking about the future.
And so if you read the book,
it starts off with some
predictions about things that
are about to happen.
So they said, we're standing on
the verge of these great,
entirely new industries
that are about to
revolutionize our lives.
And it's one of those throwaway
introductions where
they're saying things that
everybody believes is
completely true, just in order
to set up the idea that it's
important to be ready
to change.
And the interesting thing
is they made these nine
predictions in 1994 about stuff
that was imminent back
in the mid-1990s, and it's
really interesting to look
back and see what happened with
those predictions that
everybody thought
were completely
obvious at the time.
So I want to go through those.
So number one, miniature robots
built from atomic
particles that could unclog
sclerotic arteries.
So you can understand where
people would get these ideas.
There's an old science fiction
book called "Fantastic Voyage"
by Isaac Asimov.
It's still a good read today.
There was a movie done with
Raquel Welch swimming through
the bloodstream.
But anyway, the idea of if you
could just somehow miniaturize
and take tiny lasers into the
body and zap cancer or heart
blockages or things like that,
it seems really intuitive that
you ought to be able to do it.
And it seemed like it was
imminent in the mid-1990s.
But you go forward about 19
years, and you look today, and
the closest we've got
is this thing.
So this is a camera pill.
It's about the size of the end
of my finger, so it's not
particularly easy to swallow.
But the idea is that you swallow
it, and then it will
do a virtual colonoscopy as it
moves through your digestive
tract by taking pictures.
But as it turns out, it doesn't
actually do as good as
a real colonoscopy, according to
most of the stuff that I've
read, and that's about the
closest that we've gotten to
this stuff.
So we are still way, way far
away from being able to inject
robots in your bloodstream that
would go and be able to
fix things inside the body.
Second one, telephone switches
and other devices that will
provide real time translation
between people conversing in
different languages.
So we made a lot of progress
on this one, but remember,
what they're predicting here
is real time translation
between people of completely
different cultures and
languages as they're talking,
like if you met somebody on a
train or something like that.
And the translation is not up
to that point even today.
We're getting closer to it, but
you can't really do real
time continuous translation,
and that's what this was
predicting that we were on the
verge of 20 years ago.
Third, digital highways into
the home that will offer
instant access to the world's
store of knowledge and
entertainment.
That actually happened.
So they got this one
exactly right on.
And this is what a successful
prediction looks like as you
look back at it and you go,
wow, they really kind of
nailed that thing.
Fourth, urban underground
automated distribution systems
that will reduce traffic
congestion.
I don't know what they were
thinking about there.
Is it supposed to be pneumatic
tubes, or something like that?
I'm not sure.
They said it was imminent
back then.
I still don't even understand
what the projection was
supposed to be.
Next one, virtual meeting rooms
that will save people
the wear and tear
of air travel.
So this one is interesting,
because it was right and wrong
at the same time.
We've definitely gotten a
lot of progress on video
conferencing.
However, it hasn't been
used the way they
expected it to be.
So air travel has continued to
go up dramatically, even as
we've been installing
all of these video
conferencing systems.
And the reason is most business
travel, which is what
they were talking about, is done
to do one of two things.
It's either to go to
conferences, or it's to sell.
Both of those things you
have to do in person.
It's really hard to close a
sales deal with somebody when
you don't even bother to go
into their office and take
them out to drink afterwards.
What has happened, though, is
we've used videoconferencing
in a very different way to make
it possible to set up
these distributed groups that
work together on projects much
more easily than you
can do in the past.
And I've seen that myself.
The software startup that I'm
working on, we're distributed
all over the valley, but we get
together regularly over
Skype, and it's just whenever
we need to talk, we can just
get together immediately.
Forget about commuting.
We don't have to mess
with that stuff.
So they were right about the
technology, but they were
wrong about the way the market
was going to use it.
Next one, biomimetic materials
that will duplicate the
wondrous properties
of materials found
in the living room.
So National Geographic wrote
about this a couple years ago,
and they said most practitioners
conclude their
enthusiastic discourses on their
bio-inspired invention
with a few halfhearted theories
on how it may someday
make its way into
the real world.
Often, it sounds like
wishful thinking.
OK, so something that seemed
imminent back then, seems
imminent today, but is not
actually traversing into the
marketplace.
Satellite based personal
communicators that will allow
you to phone home from anywhere
on the planet.
So those do exist today.
However, compared
to cell phones,
there are some problems.
The phone is three times the
weight, the cost of a call is
$1.00 a minute, and the phone
costs $1,000 unsubsidized.
So the economics of this one
haven't worked out the way
that they were expecting.
Next, machines capable
of emotion,
inference, and learning.
I don't even know how you make
a machine feel emotion.
I'm not sure we understand how
emotion even works in human
beings, so this one does
not feel imminent.
And then, finally,
bioremediation.
So custom designed organisms
that will help clean up the
Earth's environment.
We actually do bioremediation
today with organisms.
However, they are naturally
evolved organization organisms
that we've gone out and found.
The amount of bioremediation
being done by genetically
tailored organisms is extremely
tiny, and it's still
experimental.
And by the way, that old style
bioremediation was already
being done in 1994, so
basically, the field hasn't
changed that much in terms of
fundamental technology.
So you add all these things
together, and they probably
got about two out of the
nine predictions right.
So about 22%.
Now, you might look at that and
say, well, that's not too
bad as a batting average.
It's hard to predict the future,
and at least they got
some of them right.
It was provocative thoughts,
which is kind of OK if you're
writing a book, but if you're
running a business, it's a
much bigger problem, because a
business can't go-- unless
it's Google--
and invest in all nine
of those fields.
In most cases, and even for
Google, you guys, if you're
really going to make an
investment, you've got to
focus down and put a
lot of effort but
behind a couple of things.
And if you're a business and
you go bet on one of those
nine predictions, chances are
you're going to be wrong, and
you're going to tank
the company.
And I put a little picture
up here that I think is
emblematic of that.
Anybody want to guess at what
that's a picture of, that
thing there?
So it's obviously a satellite,
but do you know
what sort of satellite?
AUDIENCE: Iridium?
MICHAEL MACE: Iridium.
Oh, very, very good.
OK, that is in iridium satellite
paid for by Motorola
to tune of about $2.6 billion.
And Wired celebrated it by
calling that product Edsels in
the sky, and it was one of the
factors that led to part of
Motorola ending up being a part
of Google today, because
the company wasn't able
to sustain itself.
So the consequences when a
company takes a flyer on one
of these predictions can
be incredibly severe.
And we need to do a better
job if we're going to be
successful as businesses.
So the question you want to ask,
then, is why is it that
we get these predictions
wrong so often?
And this is another observation
that I've gotten
into after watching companies
in the Valley and in
technology in general for
a long time is that most
companies tend to fall into one
of two buckets in terms of
how they think about
the future and how
they look at it.
And I've labeled those visionary
companies and
analytical companies.
So visionary companies are
companies usually led by a
relatively charismatic leader
who has an idea about what's
going to happen, and come hell
or high water, everybody in
the company is going to work in
support of that vision, and
we're all going to just go do
it, and we'll make it happen,
and I don't really care what
anybody says about whether or
not it's possible.
Analytical companies are kind
of the opposite extreme.
What they do is they tend to
try to use careful market
research, other sorts of
analysis, to figure out
exactly what the future is going
to look like, almost
like a weather report.
And then you just plan for the
future weather that you're
expecting to have happen.
So examples of these two
types of companies.
The one that people always
talk about for visionary
companies is Apple
under Steve Jobs.
Visionary leader, decided what
was going to happen, everybody
went and worked on it.
It didn't matter if
you objected.
You could go work
someplace else.
And they were just going to go
implement on that stuff.
I think Amazon, you can make a
very good argument that they
tend to operate much the same
way when they place some of
the big bets that they make.
But there are others that
haven't been as successful.
I spent about six years at Palm
and PalmSource, and that
was a visionary leader led
company that kind of ran out
of vision over time and got into
some serious problems.
And I'll talk about the types of
problems you can get there.
You also get a lot of companies
that sound wonderful
at the time, and they actually
tend to enter our mythology of
great companies that people
get nostalgic about, but
they're financial disasters.
And that's stuff like DeLorean--
you know, the
DeLorean Motor Vehicle
Company--
or my personal favorite, the
Roton Rotary Rocket.
Anybody ever hear
about this one?
So it goes up like a rocket,
comes down from space like a
helicopter.
And they actually got to the
point where they did a couple
of flight tests before they
completely ran out of money.
And still, though, it was
a beautiful, beautiful
technological idea.
So the rate of failure in these
visionary companies is
actually really, really high.
The ones that succeed are
really successful.
But far more often,
you get failures.
The second one is analytical
companies, and these tend not
to be as celebrated in our
culture, I guess because the
idea is that a visionary is
good, and analytical is kind
of wimpy, or something
like that.
But actually, a lot of these
are the most successful
companies in the economy.
So I'd argue GE is a
great example of
an analytical company.
Samsung, the other big consumer
electronics companies
in Asia are almost all
analytical fast followers.
They watch what happens
in the marketplace.
They respond very quickly to
changes, and they follow
behind the leadership that
other people are doing.
Very successful business
model.
When it's done right, they're
fabulously successful companies.
As visionary companies get
older, they tend to eventually
convert into analytical
companies once the leaders
aren't there anymore.
So that's like IBM, HP, classic
case of a company
that's very, very analytical,
and actually
very cautious today.
Adobe's another really, really
good example of that.
So it's not that visionary
or analytical are
either better or worse.
It's just that each of those
types of companies has some
strengths and some weaknesses
that you need to be aware of,
and they both have
vulnerabilities when they're
thinking about the future.
So strengths of the analytical
companies.
As I mentioned, very, very good
at responding to market
changes, because they're always
monitoring for those things.
They do a great job on cost
effectiveness and efficiency
and things like that.
And if you put them in a
predictable industry where
change is something that's
relatively easy to anticipate,
they can be totally relentless
at just running down whoever
the leader is and just chewing
them apart financially.
The weaknesses are, first of
all, these companies tend to
be vulnerable to group think.
If you are always scanning the
marketplace, saying, what are
the newest trends?
What are people talking about?
What are the things that are
going to come along?
It's very, very easy to get
co-opted by whatever is the
hot topic that people
happen to be talking
about in the industry.
And this happens especially
frequently now that we're
online, where the online
discussions tend to turn into
this echo chamber where we're
just trading the same opinions
back and forth with each
other all the time.
And you get to a point where it
seems like, well, everybody
is saying this, so
it must be true.
Like, everybody says that
tablets are a sucky business
to be in, and that we've tried
it for 20 years, and so
therefore, it's a dumb idea
to invest in tablets.
So of course it's stupid to try
to do a tablet computer.
Until somebody who was a little
more visionary managed
to do it right.
The second thing these companies
do is because
they're always looking at
logical analysis of
information, it's always
possible to get more detailed
information about your short
term problems and your short
term needs than it is
to get information--
really tangible information--
about long term opportunities.
So what they do naturally is
they tend to focus down on,
oh, we've got a problem in the
medical market, and we need to
fix our sales channel there.
And that can produce an extra
$100 million in revenue over
the next two years.
Let's put 100 people working on
fixing that sales channel.
As opposed to, well, there's
this idea on something that
might be a $10 billion business
five years from now,
but we're not really sure, and
it's really kind of nebulous.
If you're an analytical company,
you'll just naturally
weight the area where you have
more information, even though
it's lower return, and it's
more incremental, over the
stuff that's more nebulous and
further out, because it just
doesn't feel as real, and
you're trying to be
responsible and analytical
about this stuff.
It's very hard for these
companies to differentiate,
because, again, they tend to get
co-opted by the consensus.
And so what they do is they
produce the same things that
everybody else is doing,
but just with a
little tweak on it.
Oh, we'll add a little bit
of our special sauce, or
something like that, and in the
end, the sauce ends up not
being as special as you
might expect it to be.
They also get what I tend
to call mission drift.
And this is especially
challenging for Agile based
software firms in the
tech industry.
Well, what happens is, Agile
is absolutely wonderful.
I mean, I buy into it.
It's a much better way to do
software, especially when
you're online, than the stuff
that we used to use when I was
starting my career.
However, Agile teams sometimes
can shift away from doing
Agile implementation.
In other words, let's try
doing it this way.
Does that go well
with customers?
No?
Let's try something slightly
different.
Let's iterate really quickly
and run a bunch of
experiments.
To where they start doing that
same sort of experimentation
with what their fundamental
mission is.
In other words, well, it's not
selling quite as well as we
thought, so let's try focusing
on a different type of
customer, or a different
value proposition, or
something like that.
Let's just redirect.
And the VCs even feed into this
when they say, pivot!
You've gotta pivot!
Be ready to pivot!
Well, the problem is if you
pivot too much, you end up not
pursuing any particular
target.
Instead, you're pursuing
whatever's the hot thing in
the tech industry discussions
these days, and it's, oh, I've
got to be in online service, or
I've got to go do this, or
I've got to do this
other thing.
When I was at Palm, the big
trendy thing was everybody was
supposed to be an online
destination community like
AOL, because AOL was
hot at the time.
And so everybody was trying to
go re-duplicate that, and so
we were all going and building
these online destinations.
Turned out none of them turned
out to be very useful for
anybody, and as a result, a lot
of people wasted a huge
amount of money.
That's very typical of what can
happen in this situation
with mission drift
for projects.
OK, strengths of visionary
companies.
Very, very focused,
and very decisive.
Again, usually, you have a
charismatic CEO who will fire
anyone who disagrees.
So it's really easy
to stay focused.
They're also willing to invest
in the long term.
They don't care about one year
return, they don't care about
five year returns.
They're after something
that they're to
pursue in the long term.
You look at the way that Jeff
Bezos talks about Amazon, and
the type of things
that he does.
He doesn't really care if the
investors like it or not.
I mean, he cares at some
particular level, because he
doesn't totally control the
company, but for the most
part, he's just going to do what
he feels is best, and you
just should come along
for the ride.
Weaknesses of these companies.
Well, the first one is, they'll
ignore market data.
So there's that old
quote, don't
bother me with the facts.
If you're a visionary, and if
you believe in your vision,
it's not just that you'll tend
to disregard market research
and external market information,
but you will
actually sometimes feel
threatened by it.
And I've seen this with the
leaders of some visionary
organizations if they're a
little bit less personally
secure is, if you bring in
market research that says
something different from my
vision, you might actually
convince some people in
the company not to be
obedient to my vision.
And therefore, because I don't
want that sort of cross talk
going on within the company, I'm
not going to let you bring
market research in here, and
we're not going to look at
market data, because that would
just be a distraction
from what I've always
decided this right.
Now, sometimes that's good,
because it can help you keep
you focused.
But the area where it gets to be
a problem if it means that
you start ignoring information
about stuff that's going on
the marketplace that's
really important.
That can get to be really,
really tricky.
Second, they'll just
generally ignore
advice from the outside.
And these are the sorts of
companies where, because the
leader is charismatic and has
total control, they can march
the company straight off a cliff
if their vision ends up
being wrong at some point
in time in the future.
Look at what happened to Rim,
where the founders had been
proven right at one point in
time, and then later out,
turned to be wrong, refused to
reconsider what they were
doing, stayed the course, and
stayed the course so long that
they ground that company
completely down into the dust.
That's what can happen to a
visionary company when they
run out of vision.
So a great example of how this
process works and how both
visionary and analytical
companies can get themselves
into trouble is the history
of the smartphone.
And so I want to talk about that
a little bit, because I
think it's a really good
instructive example.
So early, early days of
development of the smartphone,
there was this thing
called the internet
that was really new.
So now we're talking late '90s,
something like that.
And we knew that it was becoming
very, very popular in
PCs, and it seemed really,
really obvious that because
people liked it on the PC, they
would also want to take
it across to the phone.
And so the big emphasis in the
phone industry, the consensus
that everybody had, was
we've got to move the
internet onto the phone.
And the way that we're going
to do this is things called
wireless application
protocol, or WAP.
And it looked a little
like this.
And I guess that screen
is too small for you
to be able to see.
So what you've got here is a
little tiny phone-- you know,
one of the really tiny little
phones that we can make that
you want to have in your pocket,
because it's so tiny.
It's got a keypad and a little
four way pointer here, and
then it's just a few little
lines of text with underlined
links that you can use to
go from page to page.
So it worked like the internet
in the sense that you had
hypertext that was linked
together, but it didn't have
the graphics of web pages, it
didn't have the web experience
that people were used to, it
didn't actually look like the
web at all.
It looked like just some
hypertext documents that
somebody had made up.
These phones received an
incredible amount of
investment.
I mean, subsidies up the wazoo
for the distribution of the
phones, huge companies that
were founded to create WAP
infrastructure and content
and all this other stuff.
There was only one problem with
that stuff, which is that
customers didn't like it and
didn't want to use it.
So WAP cratered completely in
terms of whether it was really
being effective at getting
the internet into phones.
Instead, what started to sell
were much bigger phones.
And this is not quite
to scale, but
that's not too far off.
They were based on the
PDAs of the time.
So it was not about bringing
in web stuff.
In fact, WAP was not
even implemented on
these phones sometimes.
But instead, it was about
personal information, managing
your calendar and address book
and other stuff like that, and
having that connected with the
phone, and also getting the
beginnings of a base
of applications.
So Palm, for instance, had
tens of thousands of
applications for a while, so we
kind of got the beginnings
of that mobile application
infrastructure.
These products started
doing better.
And so the emphasis in the
industry shifted away from
those WAP phones, and the
investment went into, OK,
these PDA enhanced phones.
And every big phone manufacturer
started licensing
these things and building them,
and it started having a
growth curve.
And that's where the industry
was really focused.
At the same time, in a secret
hideout in Ontario, Canada
there was a company called
Research In Motion that was
making alphanumeric pagers.
So I don't know if everybody
even remembers how pagers
worked these days, but it was
a way to sent text messages
without a phone, and they were
very popular back in the 1990s
for people who needed to get
short bits of information
very, very quickly.
So places like stock traders,
and government officials who
needed to be up to
date on headlines
and things like that.
And what the guys at Research
In Motion did was they
realized that they take their
pager technology and they
could apply it to email.
So they started making larger
devices that could connect
into the Outlook email that
everybody was using in
business at the time, and would
enable you to carry your
email around with you.
And eventually, they
built phone into
these devices as well.
Now, I was at Palm at the time
that this was going on, and
although people talked about
Research In Motion and the
BlackBerry devices, the
awareness of them was really
low, because the customer
penetration was mostly back
east in New York and Washington
and places like
that, so people just were
kind of blind to it.
But what happened was RIM got
this technology to mature,
they got it into all the phone
networks, they got all the
carriers to carry it, and all
of a sudden, this was the
explosive growth thing
in smartphones.
This was the majority
smartphone
in the United States.
Everybody decided they
had to copy that.
And I got into the discussions
that we had with the carriers
at the time.
Well, what they started telling
us was, well, the
future is clearly stuff like
RIM, so you need this keyboard
on these devices, and get rid
of that stupid touch screen.
It just gets scratched.
RIM doesn't have a touch screen,
so why are you guys
doing that yourselves?
And so actually, at Palm, we
spun up a project to do
non-touch screen Palm OS
devices, believe it or not.
That's how far this
process went.
So what happened was you had the
analytical companies who
were trying to look at things
analytical, and were just
responding to things that were
going on in the marketplace,
and so they were focused
on PDA phones.
RIM comes along, a visionary
company with a different type
of smartphone that was focused
on email, takes
the market by storm.
Everybody then goes and focuses
on trying to copy the
thing that RIM had done.
So we have the analytical
companies zigzagging like
this, going after
this new thing.
Then, of course, this guy comes
out with the iPhone,
which was absolutely everything
that the industry
consensus said you should
not do in a phone.
It was a touch screen, it was
focused on web stuff, it
didn't handle email particularly
well, it didn't
have a built in keyboard, so
you couldn't do your email
management.
And here's a quote from a
senior executive in the
industry when iPhone came out.
"That's the most expensive phone
in the world, and it
doesn't appeal to business
customers, because it doesn't
have a keyboard, which
makes it not a
very good email machine.
I like our strategy.
I like it a lot.
Right now, we're selling
millions and millions and
millions of phones a year.
Apple is selling zero
phones a year."
Ballmer, right?
Steve Ballmer.
That was what Steve
said about it.
And we see where things
ended up there.
So what you've got is a repeated
pattern of analytical
companies following the
consensus, driving themselves
into kind of a corner, a
visionary company comes in
with something else, grabs
tremendous market share,
everybody goes and tries to
chase that, and then another
visionary company comes
along and is able to
change things again.
So it's this back and forth.
For a while, RIM was really hot,
because they had a good
vision for this stuff.
Then they ran out of momentum on
that vision, Apple came up
with something different, and
then RIM ended up trying to be
a follower.
So what do you do about this if
you're in this situation?
How do we prevent these
things from
happening to our companies?
Well, I think what you need to
do is you need to change how
you think about the future.
That analytical viewpoint and
that visionary viewpoint both
have big flaws.
So you cannot completely control
the future, no matter
how good a visionary you are.
Things will happen that are
beyond your control.
And you cannot completely
predict
what's going to happen.
However, you can influence what
will happen in the future
if you have a good idea of what
the possibilities are.
The future isn't
fixed in place.
It's a thing that's in motion.
So what you really want to
look at is, what are the
things that are potentially
changing?
What are my options, and
therefore, what can I try to
cause to happen in the future?
What we need is something like
the roadmap that you use when
you're planning a road trip.
So we're in California, right?
So have you done this
on vacation?
You pack up the car, and you go
drive to someplace like a
Yosemite or Yellowstone or
something else like that?
There's this really cool process
that you go through
when you're planning
those trips.
You look at a map-- either
a paper map or an
electric one online--
and you look at, OK, there's
the Grand Canyon.
And so, wow, the Grand Canyon's
really big, but there
are only couple roads in.
So I could go here to the south
rim, and then I guess I
could go over to Navajo
National Monument.
That's a really long way.
If I went up to here, that
puts me close to Zion.
So I could go here, and
I could go up to
this one, or I could--
I can't go over here.
There are no fricking roads, so
let's not worry about that
one too much.
But let's string together
the destinations
that we could go to.
So just as a roadmap tells you
the potential things you could
and could not do in planning a
vacation, a strategic roadmap
for a company tells you the
things that you might and
might not be able to accomplish
in the marketplace
so that you can plan out which
ones you want to go after.
It's not a prediction.
It's a set of possibilities that
we can make much, much
finer grained than what most
companies are doing today.
So the elements of that future
roadmap for a company are
three things.
First of all, you've got
to understand customer
psychology.
That's like the terrain
that's on the map.
So I'm not saying market
research, like, what do people
think, or something like that.
You want to understand what
their needs are, how they
think, what things do
they care about?
Because what you're looking for
is latent subjects that
they would be interested in,
problems that they have that
you might be able to solve.
Doesn't really matter what they
think today, because they
may not understand that those
problems are solvable.
They may not even realize
that they're problems.
But if you can get inside their
heads, and if you can
look at, well, OK, I would be
able to solve this problem if
I did X and Y, that's the
beginnings of mapping out what
are the great destinations
that you could go to.
Like, for instance,
what RIM said.
Well, email's really important
to people.
Nobody's asking for a mobile
email product.
But if we took their email and
we made mobile, wow, that
would probably really go
over well with people.
Let's go ahead and try that.
Second, an understanding
of technology futures.
So that's like the roads.
Can we get there?
There's some destinations the
customers might actually love,
but we simply can't reach
it, because the
technology isn't ready.
Whereas there are other
places, well, we could
definitely go there, and it's a
good cost, and we'd be able
to do it pretty quickly.
Let's add that to the list
of things that we
really try to consider.
And then the third piece
is competitive insight.
And not traditional competitive
analysis in this
industry, which is usually about
testing somebody else's
products and getting
speeds and feeds.
I'm talking about understanding
the psychology
of your competitors so that you
will understand how they
will react when you do something
in the future.
Because something that's
different about a business
roadmap as opposed to planning
a vacation is that for a
business roadmap, you have to
take into account, well, maybe
somebody else is going to get to
the Grand Canyon before me,
and they will buy every camping
spot in the Grand
Canyon before I get there.
And if they're going to be able
to do that, I probably
don't want to plan on going
to the Grand Canyon.
I probably should drive straight
to Zion instead.
And so you have to think about
those things, and you have to
map that out.
And the way to do that is you
understand your competitors
well enough that you can figure
out what they're going
to do in the future before
they even realize it.
And it is possible to do that.
So you've got to take those
three perspectives and you
integrate them together into
a single view that lets you
think about what's going to
happen in the market overall.
What are the possibilities that
I could do if we invest
properly, and therefore, what
are the opportunities that we
could get at before
anybody else does?
So you could ask, and people
sometimes ask me, why those
three things?
Why competition and customers
and technology in particular?
Very often, those are the things
that produce the errors
that we make in our predictions
about the future.
So, for example, that satellite
phones thing was
basically an error in
underestimating the
competition.
If you'd really thought through
clearly what the
economics of cell phone
technology would be and where
that's likely to go and what's
going to go on with that, you
would have been able to see, you
know, that satellite stuff
is just not going to scale
the way we want the
cell phone stuff to.
And oh, by the way, the phone's
going to have to be
really heavy, because we need
this huge battery to be able
to talk to a satellite several
hundred miles up, as opposed
to talking to a cell phone
station that's maybe a mile
away or something like that.
And battery life is always a
problem in the tech industry.
And therefore, we know we're
going to have a battery life
problem, and that's
a crippling issue
for us to deal with.
That teleconferencing thing
was a market error.
They were right about the
technology, but they were
wrong about how customers
were going to use it.
And frankly, if you just thought
through why do people
do business travel?
What are the things they're
trying to accomplish?
It would have been pretty
fricking obvious that in most
cases, you can't use
teleconferencing to replace
most of the sources of business
travel, but that
there might be other problems
that customers have that
they're not even thinking
about that you
might be able to solve.
And then those clot
busting robots.
That was just a technology
error, plain and simple.
If you think about actually
building an autonomous little
swimming robot that can go in
your bloodstream, could swim
to a clot, would have little
graspers or manipulators or
lasers or something that would
blast the clot, but you can't
throw little pieces of the clot,
because those would go
and cause other embolisms
within the body.
You have to actually grab those
pieces and hide them or
hold them or something
like that.
And oh, by the way, if the robot
breaks down, you have to
make sure that it doesn't
turn to a clot itself.
And you have to figure out
how to power that thing.
You have to give it enough
intelligence that it can work
autonomously, or you have to
figure out some way to control
it from the outside
without wires.
I mean, come on, guys.
That's like science
fiction stuff.
That is like "Fantastic Voyage."
We're not close to
being able to do that,
even today.
And so it was crazy to think
in the mid-1990s that you
could do that.
And if they'd thought through
the real technological issues
around that, that was something
they could have been
anticipated.
So the benefits of doing
this roadmap.
For a visionary company, what
you use this for is to deepen
the vision that's being driven
by the founders.
So it's not in competition
with their stuff.
It's more like due diligence.
So, OK, here's your vision of
the marketplace that we're
going to build.
Here's how customers actually
respond to that.
Here's what they think, not in
terms of oh, they don't see it
and they don't get it, but do
they really have that problem?
Are they emotional about
that problem?
Are there other things that
they care about more?
Very often, it's so easy for
us in the tech industry to
convince ourselves that the
solution that we have is
solving a problem that the
customers really care about.
But unless you very carefully
validate that, a lot of times
what you end up doing is a
problem that the customers
don't find very motivating.
And as a result, you don't get
much revenue and much growth.
For the analytical companies,
what it does is it breaks you
outside of that analytical box,
and it helps you think
more creatively.
Because in the process of
getting those competitive
people and the market
researchers and the
technologists to bounce ideas
off of each other, they'll
start to say things like, well,
you know, if we put
together this and this and this,
that might be really
big, and that could be
a new possibility.
You wouldn't have thought
that otherwise.
You wouldn't have come
up with it through
an analytical process.
It's more like enhanced
brainstorming.
But what it does for an
analytical company is it makes
those vague future possibilities
more tangible.
It fleshes out the story and the
logic behind them a little
bit better so that you can start
to evaluate those future
possibilities with a little bit
more rigor and trade them
off against the short term stuff
that always seems more
compelling.
So in both cases, what that road
map can do is it fills in
some of the gaps in the mental
model that companies are
building in their thinking
about the future.
So why don't we build
these things today?
Organizationally, most companies
in the Valley are
not set up to do this sort of
work, because those three
groups that I talked about are
in completely different
locations, if they even exist,
and they are managed in
totally different ways with
different cultures.
So, for instance, competitive
analysis.
In most companies these days,
there is not even a
competitive analysis group.
It's something that's done by
junior product managers.
So somebody comes in, and
they're a college intern or
something like that, and you
say, hey, you're just learning
the industry.
Let me have you go do the
competitive analysis.
Go try this product and come
back to me with a paper on
it-- write up five pages,
or something like that.
And we feel like that's
really good.
But here's the deal.
If your new college intern
is doing your competitive
analysis, how much insight are
they going to come up with on
the deep psychology of the
competitors that you're
dealing with?
Because that's really the value
that you want to get is
how do they think, and what
are they going to work on?
Not just some details about
product features or
something like that.
Furthermore, what happens to the
careful knowledge that you
gained about the competitor when
that intern then goes on
back to college or goes to some
other company to work or
something like that?
You haven't established a
knowledge base within the firm
about how competitors think.
Instead, you just scattered
that out to other places.
So rather than treating this
as a throwaway junior data
collection function, you need
to treat it as a senior
analytical function that's on
par with other strategy stuff.
You get people who are really
good at this stuff, you train
them up over the years, and they
can start to develop a
knowledge base to be able to
say things like, well, you
know, when confronted with this
sort of situation that
we're talking about, here's
what Microsoft's probably
going to do, and here's what
Amazon's probably going to do,
and here's what Google will
probably do, given what I know
about their senior management
and their culture and all that
sort of stuff.
And you can actually, once you
get experienced with this, you
can make pretty good predictions
about how they're
going to behave.
Second, market research, in most
companies, is a separate
service group.
It usually reports
into marketing.
So it's doing usually research
on awareness and consideration
and other marketing metrics that
marketing cares about.
Maybe they'll do an occasional
project for a product team
that's working on stuff.
But usually, even that, it'll
be not so much about
understanding customer needs,
but it'll be more about how
are they going to react
to this product?
Here's the marketing message
that we want to try,
or things like that.
What you really want to get
to from market research is
understanding the psychology of
customers so that you can
predict their future behavior,
just like the way you try to
predict the future behavior
of competitors as well.
To do that, you have to
spend a long time
dealing with the customers.
It's years of research.
And you need the same people
working on it over time so
that you can build up that
institutional knowledge of
here's how customers think,
here's what they would like if
we built it for them.
And then third, advanced
technology to the extent that
companies in the Valley still
have dedicated advanced
technology teams, and that's
become relatively
rare over the years.
They usually work in isolation,
and what they do is
long term projects that they
cook up on their own that tend
to be stuff that engineers
are really interested in.
Kind of fundamental
breakthroughs, as opposed to
advanced development of stuff
that's actually been vetted
with market research and
competitive analysis to figure
out if it actually does
something that'll make sense
to the rest of the company.
In addition, because those
advanced technology people, in
most companies, tend to work
in isolation, even if they
come up with a brilliant idea,
it's incredibly hard for them
to sell it to the rest of the
company, because they don't
have the expertise in marketing
and in competitive
stuff to be able to explain,
here's how we'd actually win
in the marketplace.
Instead, it's just, look at this
beautiful thing I built.
Don't you want to build it?
Well, no, we're busy.
And so that's why most advanced
technology projects
in most companies never get
transferred into mainstream
production.
So you put those three groups
together, and you get the
synergy between them, and then
you're starting to do advanced
modeling of the marketplace,
including all these different
aspects, and you can actually
build up some pretty good
models about here's how things
might develop, here are some
opportunities that we
might want to go
after in the future.
And you can see this stuff
before other companies do.
So that is the first 30
pages of the book,
believe it or not.
After that, the rest of it is
this big how-to guide on how
to implement those ideas I
was just talking about.
So how to manage those three
teams, details about how to
get them to work together,
because they have very
different cultures, and just
out of box, they will not
respect each other.
In fact, they think each other
are idiots, usually.
How do you produce one
of those roadmaps?
What are the steps
you need to take?
How do you distribute it
within the company?
And then specific topics
about problems that
companies run into.
How do you segment the market
for a new product?
How do you identify your first
market segment that you're
going to go after?
How can you use this stuff to
lead Agile development and
avoid mission drift?
How do you use it?
Because the Agile team does need
to be improvising on the
how it does things.
You just don't want them
improvising on the what.
And if you do a roadmap right,
it can do this nice job of
constraining the team and
keeping them focused.
Managing the adoption curve.
How do you go from
early adopters?
How do you know when you've
moved from early adopters to
mainstream?
There's a bunch of
stuff about that.
And then a really important
issue, especially in big
Silicon Valley companies, is
managing internal politics.
Because if you are taking this
roadmap and trying to tell the
company what to do, you
inevitably can run into
resistance, unless you've been
very, very careful about how
you set it up.
So I talk about some
of that as well.
So what do I want you to
remember out of this
discussion?
So first of all, we think
about the future
in the wrong way.
We either tend to try to have
this vision that's this
all-encompassing thing that
cannot possibly be wrong, and
we try to drive the world
to that vision.
And occasionally, if you're
Steve Jobs, you get lucky, and
that works out.
But for the most part, it
doesn't work at all, which is
why you get all those
failed companies
like the Rotary Rocket.
Or you get a company that's
successful once because it got
lucky, and then it continues
to try to be visionary, and
they're never visionary
again, and it ends up
screwing things up.
And then those analytical
companies, because they're
trying to just look at tangible
stuff, tend to miss
the longer term opportunities
that are really
hard to make tangible.
So, second, if you want to deal
with that, what you've
got to do is set up this roadmap
function or something
like it that will play
counterpoint to your own
thinking style.
So if you're analytical, it kind
of pulls you out of your
comfort zone and
makes you think
about longer term vision.
If you're visionary, it tests
your ideas rigorously against
real world data so that you
can make those ideas
stronger-- not to replace
them, but
to make them stronger.
Creating a strategy
roadmap really
helps with this process.
So you want to put together your
customer thinking, what
you can build, and what the
competitors are going to do.
And ultimately, what that lets
you do is anticipate future
things that you might be able
to do in the marketplace to
pick the ones that
you want to do.
Basically, rather than trying
to predict the future, pick
out the potential future that
you want to create and then go
get everybody aligned against
creating that future.
That's really the right way
to plan for the future.
So with that, I'll take
time for discussion.
Here's my contact info.
So that's my email, that's where
you can get at the book,
and that's where my blog is,
and that's me on Twitter.
So with that, thank you very
much for your time, guys, and
if you have any questions,
I'd be glad to take them.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I'm curious what
your thoughts are about
transitioning between visionary
and analytical companies.
Either you try to do it, or
you're forced to do it.
Like in the case of Apple, they
lose a visionary leader,
and maybe there's nobody
there to replace them.
MICHAEL MACE: Yes, so
transitioning between a
visionary and an analytical
company.
Really, really hard to do.
Usually, it fails.
Apple tried to prepare
really hard.
And it's not clear, by the way,
that Apple has decided
that it wants to be an
analytical company.
They did a huge amount of
training on how did Steve
think, and what would Steve do,
and that sort of stuff,
not in the sense that they
wanted people to literally
say, well, what decision
would Steve have made?
But it's kind of like, what
were the mental habits?
How did he look at the world?
And the interesting question
about Apple is, are they going
to be able to institutionalize
that visionary function?
Do they have some people in
house who can do that stuff?
Or do they need to convert
themselves over to analytical?
The problem with trying to
convert to analytical is
almost all of your business
processes need to be changed.
If you're going to be
analytical, you need a lot
more process inside.
You need different sorts of
managers who can do analytical
thinking, as opposed to the
people you've hired to
implement your vision, who are
very tell me what to do, let
me just carry it out.
You need people who can kind
of think about stuff more.
So it is a really, really
hard thing to do.
And usually, what happens
is the companies fail.
If they've got enough runway,
if they've got enough money,
then it's easier to make that
transition, as they've got
more time, and Apple certainly
has a ton of money.
So it'll be interesting
to see how it goes.
But there's no exact playbook
for how to do it.
It's a great question,
but there's no single
way to make it happen.
AUDIENCE: Basically, principles
discussed here, the
propensities of two types of
thinking, I think also maybe
apply to the individual level.
MICHAEL MACE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So people tend to have
this intuitive thinking
or analytical.
So can you comment on those kind
of things based on your
[INAUDIBLE]?
MICHAEL MACE: Yeah.
So individuals who are either
intuitive or analytical in the
way they approach things--
which is
completely true, they exist--
the big thing is, make sure that
you are at a company that
respects whatever your style is,
and make sure you're in a
role that rewards that stuff.
So for instance, if you're a
really analytical thinker, and
you're just doing analysis, you
probably actually don't
want to try to do competitive
analysis, because usually, you
have limited data available on
competitors, and you have to
form a lot of conjectures about,
OK, based on the little
things that I know, here's
what they're
probably going to do.
However, if you're analytical,
you could be a really, really
good market researcher, because
so much of that is
dealing with data.
So it's find a job that
will use your
strengths, number one.
And number two, work in a
company-- it doesn't have to
be, oh, I'm a visionary,
therefore, I want to be in a
visionary company.
In fact, if you're a visionary,
and you work in a
visionary company, that can be
very, very uncomfortable,
because your vision may
not be the same as the
vision of the CEO.
You'll just get your butt fired
really, really fast.
But find a situation where the
company will let you do what's
your special added value, will
respect it, and will let you
go optimize the thing
that you're best at.
That's the big thing.
And it's not a particular
job title.
It's do your managers understand
what you do?
Do you understand what you're
good at so that you can
describe that to them?
It's back to my general rule for
all career management in
the Valley.
Get hired for the
right reason.
Get hired because they really
understood you, not because
you made a good pitch
for a job.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Also, just a followup, since
you're at Google, you have
that scale, right?
One side or the other side.
Where do you put Google?
MICHAEL MACE: Yeah, excellent.
I was hoping somebody was
going to ask that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL MACE: So where
is Google on that?
Is Google a vision led company
or an analytical company?
And I'll give you my take, which
I don't expect all of
you to agree with.
But this is me on the outside
having watched Google a lot is
that, although a lot of people
want to always say that Google
is a visionary company, because
it did so much to
found the internet, and there
are projects that you guys are
doing that are definitely
visionary-- like I'd say the
self driving car and Google
Glass and things like that are
pretty much visionary things,
the core of the company
behaves like an analytical
company.
That is the process
that you guys do.
Your emphasis on data and
quantification, on
understanding things, that's all
normal behavior for when
engineers are running the show,
because engineers are
trained in the scientific
method.
Scientific method says you run
a series of experiments that
you then evaluate rigorously.
You can have intuition, but
intuition that hasn't been
tested through experiment
is distrusted by
the scientific method.
And you see that sort
of behavior
repeatedly within Google.
I'll give you one little tell
that me as a competitive guy
looks at a lot is just how
do companies talk about
themselves?
There's a phrase that the
internet companies developed a
long time ago, which is, if you
can measure it, you can
improve it.
That was the whole rationale
behind analytics and all the
other stuff that we do, looking
at your server logs,
all that other stuff.
If you can measure it, you can
improve it, which makes
perfect sense.
I do not argue with it at all.
Several times over the last
couple of years, I've heard
Google executives in public
forums flip it around.
So they don't say it that way.
What they say is, if you
can't measure it, you
can't improve it.
And if you want separately,
I'll go show you the
references to when
that's been said.
If you can't measure it,
you can't improve it.
Now, what that says mentally
is, that which we cannot
measure is irrelevant, and
therefore, should not be
considered.
If you had said that to Steve
Jobs, what would he have done
to you, if you'd been one
of his employees?
So that's how a visionary
would view
that sort of statement.
And yet, Google executives
repeatedly say that in public,
with nobody contradicting it,
nobody noticing anything about
it, nobody saying, well,
that seems odd, or
anything like that.
It is a reflection of the way
this company's behaviors and
thinking tend to be formatted.
Now, no companies is ever 100%
visionary or 100% analytical,
and you can't try to be in
the middle, by the way.
That's the worst, because you
never get anything done.
There's nothing wrong with being
an analytical company.
But my long answer to your short
question was, to me,
Google looks like an analytical
company that does
some experiments with visionary
projects on the side.
That's how it parses to me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
MICHAEL MACE: Sure thing.
AUDIENCE: Michael, you started
off with the nine predictions,
and they had about a 20 batting
average, right?
So a company that moves over
to this model, what kind of
batting average would you
expect them to have?
MICHAEL MACE: I would expect it
to be in the range of over
50%, because you can't be
perfect on execution, and a
lot times, things will just fail
in execution, even if you
anticipated everything
perfectly.
But if you can at least vet
things so that you're not
making those major competitive
errors, you're not making the
major customer errors, you're
not making the major
technology years, you're going
to at least double your
success rate, if not more.
So I would say it
went 22% to 44%.
I think the goal should
be to get over 50%.
And if you get it over 50%, the
payoff on the successful
ones will be enough to be able
to fund the ones that are not
successful.
The problem is, unless you're
like Google, which has this
huge financial engine that
supports everything, a 20%
batting average is not
enough to survive
in the major leagues.
You will lose so much money on
the limited number of ones
that you can do that you simply
will never get the big
hit that makes you successful.
But I think over 50% is a
great goal to shoot at.
But, by the way, that is
an intuitive, visionary
viewpoint of things.
I cannot prove it, because it's
hard to find a company
that's actually, in the long
term, put this sort of process
into place.
I've tried to do it at some of
the places I was at at, and at
Palm, we actually got the whole
thing in place, and then
they reorged and completely
changed direction.
It was like, come on, guys!
But I can show you all the
predictions we made back then.
Dead on.
100%.
At least I think so, from
my perspective.
AUDIENCE: When Steve Jobs
released the iPhone for
everyone, what could have been
different at the time?
How could other companies
have been more prepared?
MICHAEL MACE: Oh,
great question.
OK, so when Steve Jobs did the
iPhone, what should other
companies have done?
Well, the first thing is, they
should have been in there
ahead of time before
Steve got to it.
They should have been looking
at these issues.
But that's not a great answer,
because you'll always get
surprised sometimes
by somebody.
I think they would have been a
lot better off, number one, to
focus on what their
strengths were.
So what RIM did which was
really, really wrong--
provably wrong--
is that they tried to turn their
product into an iPhone.
So they tried to add
entertainment features and
browsing and stuff, and there
was all this advertising that
was focused, rather than
focused on their core
customers in the enterprise, it
was focused on consumers.
So I don't know if you remember
the Verizon, oh your
BlackBerry butt dialed me ad,
because the kid had sat on his
BlackBerry, and now there's a
BlackBerry with a flip cover?
And I thought, man, that is
really appealing to a business
executive, you know?
And that's really going to
reinforce your core customers
that you're good at.
If they had really, really
focused on, what
do we have at RIM?
We have this great
client server
architecture at the back end.
We have email.
Let's focus on enabling all the
other enterprise apps, and
let's make sure that we can
mobilize that stuff better
than anybody else.
They might have been able
to hang onto the entire
enterprise market, and then
the iPhone would have been
niched as a consumer
entertainment device that's
not appropriate for business,
and it would have been stuck
in the same position that
Macintosh was in for a long
time relative to Windows.
Windows is right for
business, Macintosh
is right for creatives.
Creative market is this big,
business market is this big.
Instead, RIM tried to chase
Apple, made itself a bad
business tool and a bad
entertainment tool at the same
time, really cratered
the business.
So my usual answer is, know what
you're best at, know who
your customers are, stay the
course, do a great job of
differentiating.
Don't try to own
100% of market.
Own your segment of the market,
and don't worry about
the rest of it.
And that's what I
would have done.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering what
determines the company pick,
either the visionary
or the analytical.
Is it because of the leader, or
because of certain segments?
MICHAEL MACE: How does a company
end up being either
visionary or analytical?
There are different industries
that have different balance.
So for instance, if you look at
the entertainment industry,
most of them, even though they
try to be analytical, most of
them are vision driven.
They just don't know which
movies are going to make it.
And it's their gut feeling
about, I trust this director,
I trust this producer,
or this is what I
think is a good direction.
Now, they do sometimes behave
like analytical companies in
the sense that they'll all try
to copy each other if one of
them's successful.
Oh, Tolkien movie did well.
Let's all do fantasy
movies about elves.
And you get a bunch of things
like that, so you do get some
of that behavior.
But still, you get some
industries that are much more
visionary than others.
However what usually drives
it is the founders.
And you can have founders who
are very vision driven, like a
Steve Jobs.
He's just ego.
Force of will, man.
He decided he was right, and you
were going to follow him,
and that's what it
was going to be.
You get other companies that
have a more analytical point
of view in their founders, and
that tends to color the
behavior of the whole company.
Why does Google focus so much
on testing things and
analyzing things and
stuff like that?
Well, you've got some guys
who are trained PhDs in
engineering who have a really
strong science background, and
that's how they're trained to
think about things and to
approach problems.
And like I said, one isn't
better than the other.
The big thing is, understand
which one you are, do a really
good job of executing on it,
but then watch your blind
side, which is what this
road map thing's about.
AUDIENCE: Something I really
like about Google here is we
are given the opportunity to
criticize, to say we don't
like things.
But now, the question
is, how to get that
into actionable items?
We are good criticizers, but
I'm not sure we change the
road, the path.
MICHAEL MACE: So being able to
criticize well versus being
able to actually drive action.
So I'm on the outside, and so I
have a blind spot to how the
details of decision making
processes work within Google,
because you guys are very
careful to keep that sort of
internal stuff confidential.
So what I'll say in general, and
this is just about dealing
with human beings in general,
especially if you're in an
analytical culture, is you
can't just critique.
You've got to be persuasive.
The more you can flesh out the
reason that you're critiquing
something, what is the reasoning
behind it, the more
that people are going to
tend to listen to it.
Now, th e problem is going to
be, if you've got a visionary
idea that you're trying to
critique from a visionary
perspective, that's a really
hard thing to get across in
any company that tends to be
analytical, because it's just
my opinion.
It's like, because of the
scientific method, you always
listen to critiques.
That's absolutely fine.
I would expect Google to be a
great place for people doing
criticism, because that's
how scientists
are supposed to work.
Peer review, right?
We toss our ideas around, we
peer review, you fire away,
you throw things at me, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
However, ultimately, peer review
you listen to, and then
you're allowed to dismiss
it if you're in charge.
A lot of it depends
on the managers
above, and do they listen?
Do they force the people who
are making the decisions to
actually take into account
criticism?
And then it's how persuasive can
the person who's doing the
criticism be.
And part of that is thinking
about this roadmap process.
OK, why do you criticize it?
Why do you think it's wrong?
How much of those perspectives--
if you look
from all those different
perspectives, can you set up
an intellectual framework for
explaining why it's wrong, as
opposed to just saying,
here's my opinion?
The more you can put a framework
around it, the
better chance you have of
getting people to listen to it
and listen to it constructively
in the sense
of, OK, you've given me some
ideas to work on, as opposed
to, oh, you're disagreeing
with me, you're
messing with my job.
I don't want to hear about
that sort of stuff.
So think about how you could put
a framework around things.
I apologize.
I know that's really kind of a
vague answer, but that's the
best I can do from a distance.
But I'd be glad to talk to you
more about it offline, if you
want to brainstorm sometime.
AUDIENCE: First of all, I want
to say thank you for the talk.
MICHAEL MACE: My pleasure.
AUDIENCE: You had a lot of
really good examples of
visionary companies and
analytical companies, but I
was wondering, do you have any
examples of companies that
have managed that
transition well?
MICHAEL MACE: Companies that
have managed the transition
from visionary to analytical?
AUDIENCE: Or vice versa.
MICHAEL MACE: Yeah.
You know, I think HP, for a
long time, did it well.
I mean, it was always an
engineering oriented company,
so it was a little bit
analytical to begin with, but
the founders had pretty strong
ideas about places they wanted
to go, and they were willing to
place bets on those things,
even if they didn't have a lot
of data backing it up.
And I think for a long
time, HP did OK as
an analytical company.
They've lost their way today,
but if we talked about it 10
years ago, I would've said
they're a pretty good model
for how to make that go.
3M is a really interesting one
to look at, because they're
the closest to a company that's
both visionary and
analytical, and really, I wish
I knew more about them.
I've talked to some people from
3M about the processes
that they use.
What's interesting is they
can be very good at being
analytical about understanding
how they identify engineering
breakthroughs.
They're really good at, for
instance, numerically being
able to identify the most
creative engineers who are
likely to produce the biggest
breakthroughs.
They've done a great job of
getting through that.
Really cool stuff, if
you haven't seen it.
But they will tell you, trying
to figure out who can produce
the breakthrough thinking on
a market as opposed to an
engineering innovation,
they have no clue.
It's like, I was talking
with one of them.
It's like, we don't know.
Like, maybe we look at
their track record.
But of course, by the time you
look at their track record,
they've already done it, and
you haven't grab those
employees at the time when
they can help you out.
So it's a real tricky one, and
other than HP, I have trouble
thinking of a lot of other
really good examples.
But good question.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So if you're working
in a strong, visionary
company, right, and if I take
your recommendation on taking
some analytical components to
balance it out, or at least to
look at the other side of the
coin, right, what are the top
talking points if you're talking
to an executive or
whatever to basically make them
consider the other side
of the coin?
And again, vice versa, right?
So if you're talking to an
executive in a company where
they're very analytical, but
you're trying to basically
sell this idea of incorporating
the other side
of the coin, how
do you do that?
What are the top three selling
points for each of those?
MICHAEL MACE: Oh, that's
a great question.
OK, so trying to convince a
visionary company to listen to
your analytical type thinking.
Number one, you need to get a
read on the character of the
CEO of the company--
of your visionary.
Whoever the CEO is.
They might be the CEO, they
might be the general manager
of a business unit, if
the business units
have a lot of autonomy.
You've got to get a read on
their personality, and how
insecure are they?
Because what you can get is
you can get people who are
visionaries who have a fair
amount of personal insecurity,
where they view any challenge as
a personal threat to them.
And that's just not a good place
to try to feed ideas to
them, because they don't have
enough self confidence to be
able to listen to dissenting
ideas.
If they feel secure, though,
what you can do is you can
feed it to them as this
is a way to make
your vision even stronger.
I'm not trying to replace
your vision.
What I'm trying to do is test
it out against some things
that will help you spot
potential blind spots.
And by going through this
process of roadmapping,
thinking through these things,
what we're going to produce is
something that we will bring
straight to you-- we're not
going to take to the whole
company first, we'll bring it
right to you.
And what we'll do is we will let
you think through it, and
you can look at, oh, I hadn't
thought about this issue.
Gee, I've got to reconsider
this.
Or, yep, I've got to
work that one.
Or no, here's why I think
you guys are wrong.
But you will have a higher
percentage chance of success,
because it's been tested.
It's just like exercise.
And usually these execs are
really into exercise.
If you sell it like exercise--
this is mental exercise to try
to make your ideas stronger--
they'll tend to go for that,
as long as they have enough
self confidence that
they don't feel
threatened by that thing.
Now, let me flip it around.
Analytical companies tend very
often to be rather than top
down, they tend to
be bottom up.
So it'll be, I want
ideas to come up
from within the company.
I want those to boil up to us.
I want to create processes by
which we get ideas internally,
and we vet them, and other
things like that.
To those executives, you sell
this roadmap thing as an
additional process that will
produce better quality
thinking around long
term opportunities.
And you sell them on,
you know what?
We prioritize short term easy
stuff much higher than we
prioritize the long term
difficult stuff that might
produce the big returns.
That's a logical, analytical
view of the problem that they
can buy into.
And then what they'll say is,
OK, Mr. Smart Guy, what do we
do about it?
Well, we're going to run this
run this roadmap process that
brings out those intuitive vague
ideas that people have
that vets them and helps to
draw out scenarios of how
things could develop in the
future so that you can view
them as a more realistic
thing.
You can get a better sense of
what might be possible, and
you'll be able to think
ahead of where
competitors are thinking.
That's a way to hook them.
OK so going by this process, I,
Samsung, can get someplace
faster than the Nokias
of the world.
And therefore, I'm going to have
a bigger advantage in the
marketplace.
Great.
Let's do it.
Let's go try it.
And then it's a matter of
executing on it and making
sure that they can see the
benefits of it over time.
So work from their angle.
Visionary companies tend to be
top down, so sell it from the
top down as a way to
improve their own
thinking through exercise.
Analytical companies tend
to be bottom up.
Sell it to management as a way
to get better quality thinking
coming out of the company.
That's the short answer.
And there's more details
in the book.
So I'm trying not to pitch the
book, but if you want look at
that, there's some stuff.
But also, if you want to talk
about it some more, I'd be
glad to chat about it offline.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Thank you.
MICHAEL MACE: Thanks.
So thank you very
much for coming.
I really, really
appreciate it.
I'll stick around for a few
minutes, if you've got other
questions and stuff.
You also can contact me there.
I would love to get
feedback from you.
And thank you so much
for your time.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]